one of the big struggles that this young
generation gen y
and gen z are struggling with is is
they're ill-equipped with the skills
required for uh
being a successful human being and what
i mean by that is um
uh so much of their relationships exist
online so much of their communication
exists
over text or direct message that that
there's a generation
unfortunately there are too many of them
who literally aren't learning the skills
of how to talk to people um you know i i
heard a story of somebody who
they have a 14 year old when the
doorbell rings they can't answer the
door because they're too scared to talk
to the stranger
well it sounds funny when you're a 14
year old
but that's gonna hurt when you're older
um
you know the the ability to form deep
meaningful relationships the ability to
have difficult conversations
too many kids these days if they want to
break up with their girlfriend or
boyfriend
they just ghost them they could have
been dating for months it's not i'm not
talking about like
after one date and it doesn't work out i
don't care about that i'm talking about
you're dating somebody
for three or four months and you decide
it doesn't work out so the way you're
too scared to have a confrontation
so you just don't reply to any of their
texts and unfollow them on all social
media
which is unbelievably traumatic for the
person on the receiving end it's like a
death for them
right like you there's a panic what
happened to them all the self-doubt
so it destroys self-confidence all
because one person was too chicken
to say i don't think this is working out
um these are absolutely essential skill
sets because when you're a leader
difficult conversations is one of the
things you have to have
we call you leader not because you have
rank we call you leader not because
you're at the top of the organization we
call your leader
not because somebody promoted you we
called you leader because you have the
courage to go first
we call you leader because you went
first towards the danger first to take
the risk
first to trust i will give you trust
without expecting trust back
that's called leadership i will approach
you and give you difficult feedback that
everybody knows but everybody's afraid
to tell you so that you can grow as a
human being
i will do that that's called leadership
i will
ask people that it's time to transition
off the team because
we have to reform this team and i love
you and you're
loyal and i'm going to make that
excruciating decision where everybody
else won't make it because they don't
want to hurt their friends feelings
and if we don't equip people at a young
age with these skills
unfortunately they're now entering our
companies without these skills
and it is now the responsibility of the
companies to teach those skills
we have no choice companies have to
teach
listening effective communication
how to give and receive feedback how to
have difficult conversations and if your
company doesn't have these classes
then then the future of leadership is
not looking good and unfortunately
the responsibility now for what falls on
the company because
we didn't do it in school and we didn't
do it in university we definitely didn't
do it at business school
so when are we gonna do it better late
than never